ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้สวัสดีครับน้องเรียม
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคน
ด้วยวะว้าวสวัสดีทุกคนเจอกันอีกแล้ววัน
นี้เจอกันเจอกันอีกแล้วเจอกันอีกแล้ววัน
นี้โอเควันนี้เราเจอกันวันที่เท่าไหร่
ครับวันนี้วันนี้วันที่ 23 ค่ะวันนี้วัน
ที่ 23 นะ
k55 ไหนครับวันนี้วันที่ 23 นี่นี่อยู่
ตรงนี้นะครับอ่าวันนี้วันที่ 23 วันที่ 23
เป็นวันอะไรครับเนี่ยวันนี้เป็นวัน
พฤหัสบดีค่ะอ๋ออ๋อใช่ครับมีวันนี้เป็นวัน
พฤหัสวันพฤหัสที่ 23
โอเคแล้วเดือนอะไรครับเนี่ยเดือนนี้เดือน
กันยายนขอเดือนกันยายนใช่ไหมนี่กันยายน
แค่เดือนกันรถยนต์แล้วปีคริสตศักราช
2021  21 ใช่แล้วอ่ะ Mini ขึ้นมาตลาด
2021 แล้วพุทธศักราชพุทธศักราช
2560  4 ใช่แล้วพุทธศักราช
2560  4-5 วันที่ 23 เรามาเรียนภาษาไทย
การว่าเรียนภาษาไทยกับน้องเรียมแล้วก็พี่
อ่าตี้ด้วยเอาแค่ไหนแล้วตอนนี้ตอนนี้ตอน
นี้กี่โมงแล้วครับหน้าตอนที่เราเรียนภาษา
ไทยวันนี้
9:30 น 9:30 น่ะ 9:30 นก็จะต้องมีนะข้าว
โมงครึ่งอยู่ตรงนี้อาชีพไปที่เลข 9 ใช่
ไหมอ่า
9:30 นครึ่งนครึ่งแบบนี้อ้าโอเค
9:30 น 9:30 ก็คือเข็มยาวนี่เข็มน่า
เกลียดอีวัดผมไม่สวยเลย
โอเคนี่ๆข้าวบ่ 6 ครึ่งจะไม่ครับ 9 โมง
แล้วก็บวกกับอีก
30 หน้าเป็น 9:00 น 17:00 นหน้าทรายแล้ว
แค่ตอนนี้ 9:30 นมาเรียนภาษาไทยกันนะครับ
โอเควันนี้น้องเรียนจะพานักเรียนพากู Arty
ไปที่ไหนอ่ะวันนี้ 5 วันนี้เราจะไปไหนกัน
องค์เรียงยาว
ยาวผมยาวผมยาวสวยแล้วครับผมยาวสวยดีๆแล้ว
ยังไงต่อเตรียมอย่างตัดขอจะไปตัดผมใช่ไหม
ไปตัดผมขออ่ะแล้วเวลาเราตัดผมเราไปตัดที่
ไหนอ่ะครับที่ร้านตัดผมนะคะก็จะมีร้านตัด
ผมมีผู้ชายร้านนี้เป็นร้านของผู้ชายใช่
มั้ยจะเรียบร้อยอ่ะร้านตัดผมชายอ๋อร้าน
ตัดผมแล้วก็มีคำว่าชายมาต่อหลังก็จะเป็น
ร้านตัดผมของผู้ชายโอเคครับเปียตีก็ไปตัด
ผมที่ร้านตัดผมผู้ชายเหมือนกันร้านตัดผม
ชาย
โอเคแล้วอันนี้อ้าโอเค
ต้องไปร้านตัดผมผู้หญิงขอร้านตัดผมผู้
หญิงเอามีของผู้ชายแล้วก็คือผู้หญิงแยก
กันใช่ไหมครับแยกกันของพูดแล้วก็ของผู้
หญิงแยกกันอยู่คนละร้าน
ได้ค่ะแต่รักของผู้หญิงจะเรียกว่า
ร้านเสริมสวยอ๋ออ้าวเรียกไม่เหมือนกันนะ 5
สถานเสริมสวยร้านเสริมสวยกันครับเวลาเรา
เช่าไปในร้านนะคะอ๋อเข้าไปในร้านแล้วอ่ะ
มีอะไรอยู่ในร้านเสริม
เจออะไรครับชัดเจอช่างตัดผมขอช่างตัดผม
ช่างตัดผมแบบนี้แบบนี้ใช่ไหม
ขอช่างตัดผม
เวลาที่เข้าไปในร้าน
เราก็จะเจอกับช่างตัดผมครับอ่ะฮะเราเจอ
ช่างแล้วเราก็บอกช่างว่าอ๋อต้องบอกด้วยนะ
อ๋อ
ครับผมทรงไหน
จะตัดผมทรงไหนน้อเวลาตัดผมเราต้องบอกช่าง
อ้าโอเคแล้วมีทรงไหนบ้างครับมีทรงไหนให้
ปัดบ้างทำเป็นทรงผมของผู้ชายนะคะอ๋ออ๋อ
ข้างบนอ่อนี่ไงนี่เป็นผู้ชายผู้ชายผมสั้น
นะอ้าเหมือนพี่อาร์ตี้พี่ก็ผมสั้นไอ้
ที่เป็นผู้ชายก็แค่ครับผู้ชายทรงแรก
นี้จะเป็นปัดข้างทรงแรกทรงนี้ใช่ไหมครับ
อ๊อฟอัดไปด้านข้าง
ปัดไปนั่งข้างหน้าปัดไปด้านข้างแล้วนี้
ปาดไปแบบนี้อ้าปัดไปด้านข้างแล้วเข้
ใช่อาหาทับส่งที่ 2 ก็จะมีผมหน้าอ๋ออ๋อ
ทรงนี้ก็จะมีผมข้างหน้าตรงนี้ใช่ไหมอ่ะ
ผมข้างหน้านะฮะกับ
ว้าวทรงนี้หล่อเบียร์ตีชอบตรงนี้
จบเข้าร้าน
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
โอเคโอเคอ้าแล้วมีส่งอะไรอีกครับตรงนี้
ส่งอะไร
ทรงนี้เรียงไม่รู้ค่ะจะส่งอะไรเตรียมไม่
รู้แต่ถ้าเกิดเข้าร้านแล้วพี่อ้ะพี่อยาก
ได้ทรงนี้เอารูปขอเอารูปไปห่าดูอ๊อดก็บอก
บอกช่างเอาทรงนี้เอาทรงนี้ขอเขาส่งเขาส่ง
นี้
ไม่ต้องพูดเยอะไม่ต้องพูดเยอะบอกว่าเอา
ทรงนี้ทรงนี้หน้าโอเคแล้วด้านล่างนะครับ
ว่ามีส่งของผู้หญิงเยอะเลย
ห่า
ให้ครับนี้ครับ
ก็จะมีผมอยาก
ผมอะไรนะครับ
ผม
อยากขอผมอยากผมอยากก็จะโค้งโค้งแบบนี้ใช่
ไหมขอขอขอ
แบบนี้
อย่าก๊อ
หาแล้วน้องเรียมอยากได้ผมอยากไหมครับ
ไม่ค่ะได้แล้วเลียมอยากได้ผมอ่อเป็นเส้น
ตรงใช่ไหมอันนี้แบบนี้เรียกว่าผมตรงใช่
ไหมผมตรงลองน่ะอ๋อผมตรงเหมือนลิซ่าเลยใช่
ไหมใช่ค่ะมาด้วยหรอตรงนี้ใช่ไหมครับตรง
นี้เรียกว่าอะไรนะครับหน้าม้าหน้าหมาหมา
อ๋อโอเคหน้าม้าขอนะหมาจะอยู่บนหน้าหน้า
เหลี่ยมใช่ไหมไม่ได้ที่อยู่บนบาสเป็นหน้า
เราก็ตรงนี้ใช่ไหมครับที่เรียกว่าหน้าม้า
ทรงขายขอที่มันที่มันตรงนี้ที่มันเข้ากัน
เนี่ยที่ตัดเป็นแนวนิอ๋ออ่อนี่หน้าม้า
โอเคแบบนี้อาลิซ่าและเมื่อลิซ่าและแนะ
ๆเปรี้ยวมีหน้าม้าแล้ว
แก 5 มีซองผมตรงใช่ไหมผมทองหน้าม้าแกตอน
นี้ส่งอะไรครับเนี่ย
แล้วก็มีผมสั้นค่ะอ๋ออ๋อผมสั้น 5 ผมสั้น
อ๋ออ๋อผมไม่ยาวผมก็จะสั้นนี่ผมจะสร้างแค่
นี้ใช่ครับก็จะไม่ยาวผมสั้นๆแบบนี้เรียก
ว่าผมสั้นๆนี่เล่าน้องเปียผมสั้นอย่างรวด
เร็วไม่ต้องไปร้านตัดผมและตอนนี้ผมไม่
ปัญหาแต่ต้องใช้มือจับไว้
โอเคอ่ะผมสั้น
แล้วมีอะไรอีกครับ
พร้อมแล้วไปออกตอนนี้เรานั่งอยู่ช่างบอก
ติดตั้งแล้วว่าจะเอาทรงไหนใช่มั้ย
เอ้อยเอาทรงนี้ค่ะทรงนี้
แล้วช่างก็จะ
มาตัดผมให้เราก็ตัดผมทรงที่เราบอกอ้าอ๋อ
อ๋อโอเคช่างก็มาตัดผมแค่ครับแล้วยังไงอีก
ครับแล้วเราต้องทำนะครับเราต้องทำยังไง
บ้างเข้าไป
ช่วยช่างตัดไหมไม่ต้องช่วยเรานั่งเฉยๆ
นั่งเฉยๆหลับได้ไหมเวลาไปตัดไม่ได้เข้าไป
ตัดผมหรอกไปได้ไหม
ไม่ได้นะอ๋อต้องต้องคอยดูต้องคอยดูช่าง
ว่าช่างตัดผมเป็นยังไงใช่ไหมห้ามหลับใช่
มั้ยอ๋ออ๋อ
ๆพี่อาร์ตี้เวลาพี่อาร์ตี้ไปตัดผมเฮียตี
ก็หลับอ่ะก็
เห็นหลับได้หรอคะได้
ตั้งก็ตากตีก็หลับ
ทางก็ตาก
ว่าช่างช่างต้องแบบ
มันโกรธ
ช่าง
ตัดไม่ได้
แค่แต่ของของผู้หญิงต้องต้องไม่หลับใช่
ไหมของผู้ชายหลับได้แค่อ่านแล้วยังไงอีก
ครับ
แล้วช่างก็จะมาตัดผมแต่ในร้านเสริมสวยนะ
คะร่างเสริมสวยจะมีทั้งสระผมไปผมมีที่ใด
ผมด้วยอันนี้หรือเปล่านี่คืออะไรครับพี่
แบบนี้
เป็นไดร์เป่าผมไดร์เป่าผมเป่าผมอ๋อเวลา
เปล่า
ขอใช้ใดๆเอาไปเป่าผมก็จะเป่าอ้าเป่าลมออก
ไปใช่ไหมหาอ่าเรารอมานี้เนี่ยลมอันนี้มัน
เป็นไงครับมันร้อนๆเป็นลมร้อนด้วยนะโอเค
ลมร้อนเป่าผมทำให้ผมเป็นยังไงครับทำให้ผม
แห้งอ๋ออ๋อถ้าเราสระผมมาแล้วผมเราก็จะ
เปรียบใช่ไหมเพราะผมเปียกชัก
เออ
เราสระผม
ผมก็จะเปลียก
หาใช่ครับ 5 ผมสับอีกออก
อาหารผมเปียกต้องเอาไดร์เป่าผมขอ
เป่าเปล่าให้ผมแห้งเจ้าสามารถม้วนผมได้นะ
ไปม้วนผมม้วนผมใช้อันนี้เหรอครับอันนี้
เป็นอะไรครับถ้าใช้เครื่องม้วนผมขออันนี้
เป็นเครื่องม้วนผม
ขอผมอ๋อ
อ๋อลงมาเราก็จะได้ผมจะเป็นลอนอ๋ออ๋อผม
เป็นลอนเป็นม้วนม้วนม้วนม้วนม้วนแบบนี้
เลยน้อโอเคก็น่าถ้าอยากมีผมม้วนๆแบบนี้
ยังมีผมม้วนแบบนี้ต้องใช้เครื่องม้วนผม
เรื่อง
เราเดินเข้าไปในร้านแล้วบอกช่างว่าม้วนผม
ค่ะอ๋อวันนี้วันนี้ไม่ตัดผมวันนี้จะมา
ม้วนผม
อ๋อโอเคครับผมเครื่องหนีบผมอ๋ออ๋อเครื่อง
หนีบนะคือมันหนีบหนีบผมอ๋อ
อ้านี่ผมแล้วเป็นยังไงครับอ่ะเตือนให้ผม
ตรงขออันนี้ใช้เป็นเครื่องหนีบผมที่ทำให้
ผมตรงถ้าผมเข้ามาอยู่ข้างในนี้ผมก็จะเป็น
เส้นตรงอย่างนี้ใช่ไหมครับใช่ค่ะอ๋ออ๋อ
นี่ผมมาก็แปลว่าน้องเรียมก็หนีบผมด้วยใช่
มั้ยเนี่ยนี่ไปอ๋อมีหน้าผมก็เลยตรง
กันใจอ่านี่กันไก่กันไก่
ใจนะครับ
กันงานก็จะมีหวีอ๋ออันนี้นี่คือหวีอ้าหวี
หวีแค่มีหวีและมีกรรไกรด้วยนะครับครับ
แต่ถ้าเกิดเป็นผู้ชายเข้าไปร้านตัดชายฮะ
ร้านตัดผมชายจะมีมีดโกนอ๋ออ๋อมีองค์กรแบบ
นี้มีแบนมิโคนเอาไว้โกนขนหนวดโกน
เครา
เคราได้โกนเคราแล้วก็คนหนวดด้วยแล้วก็มี
ปัตตาเลี่ยนไหมค่ะอันนี้ใช่ไหมครับสีดำ
อันนี้ปัตตาเลี่ยนอ๋อใช่ครับเอ่อช่างตัด
ผมของพี่อาร์ตี้ก็ใช้ปัตตาเลี่ยนในการตัด
ผม
ปัตตาเลี่ยนจะมีเสียงแบบนี้
ได้รับเฮียตีก็หลับคือ
จังก็ตัดไปอย่างดีความสุข
เตรียมกำลังจะถามที่ว่าเครียดที่ไม่
รู้สึก
นิดหน่อยนิดหน่อยนิดหน่อย
เวลาปัตตาเลี่ยนมาไทยอ่ะ
ก็สนุกดีเอาหน้าต้องลองต้องลองครับ
นี่วีคโอนอันนี้มีแต่ก่อนอ่ะใช้ก่อนหนวด
โกนเคราแล้วอันนี้ปัตตาเลี่ยนใช้ตัดผม
โอเคอ่ามีอะไรอีกครับที่เราจะไปทำกันสนุก
ๆวันนี้เสร็จหรือยังเสร็จหรือยังตัดผมนาน
แล้วเกือบเสร็จหรือยังทำอะไรอีกครับเสร็จ
แล้วค่ะเสร็จแล้วย้อมสีผมย้อมสีแบบนี้แบบ
นี้ไหมครับน้านิกรเขาเข้ามาเนี่ยครับผมก็
สีนี้นี่แต่เขาไปเปลี่ยนแม็กเปลี่ยนสี
เปลี่ยนสีผมเรียกว่าอะไรนะครับเรียกว่า
ย้อมสีย้อมสีรอบย้อมจากสี
สีทองให้เป็นสีนี้สีมีสีอะไรครับเงียบจัง
เลยว้าวโอเคสีชมพู
และย้อมสีย้อมผมสีทองให้เป็นสีชมพูก็ไป
ย้อมผมยอมปกแล้วเก้บเอียงตีก็ไม่ยอมมา
เหมือนกันเบี้ยที่ยอมนึงขาว
กุญแจ
พร้อมผมนะฮะแล้วมีอะไรให้ทำอีกครับที่
ร้านเสริมสวยวันนี้
มาทำเล็บสวยทำเล็บได้ด้วยค่ะอ๋อ
เสริมสวยนอกจากทำผมทำผมให้สวยแล้วทำผมให้
สวยแล้วยังทำเล็บเล็บนี่เล็บอยู่ตรงนี้
ทำเล็บได้ด้วยทำเล็บให้สวยอ๋อโอเค
แล้วต้องเรียนทำเลย
เรียบต้องเข้าร้านตอนนี้เล็บไม่สวย
อ๋อ OK
ก็สวยอ่าหน้าทำผมเสร็จแล้วก็ค่ำเล็บด้วย
3x ด้วย
[เพลง]
ไปค่ะแล้ววันนี้แหละตาอ่าอ่า
ย้อมผมไหมครับวันนี้น้องเรียมจะยอมไหมจอม
ไหมคำทุกอย่างค่ะทำทุกอย่าง a  r  d ครับ
แล้วก็เดินเข้าไปในร้านแล้วก็บอกช่างว่า
ตัดผมค่ะผมหน้าตัดผมด้วย
ย้อมถมของผมด้วยย้อมสีอะไรดีครับสีอะไร
อยากย้อมผมสีอะไรครับสีชมพูมั้ยก็ผัว
พูดไหมคะสีชมพูเลยหรอโอเคอ้าแล้วทำอะไร
อีกครับแล้วก็สระผมอ๋ออ๋อสระผม
ตากใจยาสระผมด้วย
ใดใดใดคืออะไรครับ
ไดร์เป่าผม
อ๋ออ๋อใดเปล่าผมไดร์ผมให้แห้งใช่ไหมขอสระ
ผมแล้วก็ไดร์ผมโอเค
ต้องบอกช่างว่า
สะใดอ๋ออ๋อสหแล้วก็ใดโอเคครับจะได้ค่ะแก
แล้วก็ทำเล็บค่ะอ๋ออ๋อทำเล็บด้วยอ่ะทำ
เล็บด้วยจะได้สวยมากขึ้นอ้าเพราะว่าเราไป
เสริมสวยแล้วโอเคครับอ้าวันนี้นักเรียน
ทุกคนสนุกกันไหมครับได้ไปที่ร้านตัดผม
เครียดที่ไม่เคยไม่เคยไปร้านตัดผมผู้หญิง
นะเนี่ยเพิ่งรู้วันนี้ที่น้องเรียนเล่า
ให้ฟังหน้าเป็นการไส้ได้ครับแล้วนักเรียน
คนไหนนะครับนักถ้าเป็นผู้ชายไปร้านตัดผม
และมีประสบการณ์สนุกๆอะไรทีให้พี่อาร์ตี้
กับน้องเรียมดูในคอมเมนต์ด้วยหรือว่านัก
เรียนคนไหนที่เป็นผู้หญิงไปแล้วร้านเสริม
สวยๆของผู้หญิงมีอะไรสนุกๆมีอะไรที่น่าสน
ใจเล่าให้พี่อ่ะพี่ฟังในคอมเม้นด้วยนะ
ครับอ่ะแล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าคราวหน้าเราจะ
พาไปที่ไหนมาคอยติดตามกันค่ะดีไหมครับ
น้องเรียมค่ะหาโอเคถ้างั้นวันนี้เลียมก็
ต้องไปตัดผมไปสะใจไปทำเล็บหน้าดีครับอย่า
ลืมย้อมผมด้วยนะอย่าพร้อมผมถ้าโอเคแล้วก็
ลาไปก่อนนะครับวันนี้สวัสดีครับทุกคน
แล้วสวัสดีน้องเตรียมสวัสดีนะคะบ๊ายบาย
[เพลง]
ไปแล้วค่ะเขาตัดผมแล้ว
ไปกันไปกัน
ยาวมาก
[เพลง]